nous sommes à hoymille sur mansion dans
le nord des yvelines c'est la 79e
édition du paris-nice le département
accueille ses leçons soleil depuis 1 12
ans
[Musique]
oh
hier c'était la commune de saint cyr
l'école qui a ouvert le bal dans les
yvelines mélanie poké étaient sur place
le soleil était au rendez vous ce
dimanche 7 mars les spectateurs un peu
moins nombreux qu'en temps normal
avec la crise de la coc u19 les amoureux
du vélo dû accepter leur frustration
paris nice est toujours un moment dans
le début de saison on peut voir les
nouvelles équipes voire voir ce qui s'y
passe
mais c'est vrai qu'avec les convives
c'est un peu plus je parte suivant vous
fait des présentations mais là du coup
on attend le début de la course
on nous a dit de venir par la voilà
après les circonstances font que c'est
compliqué quand on est on est très loin
des coureurs
cette course à huis clos à l'ambiance
particulière s'est lancé à deux pas du
lycée militaire de saint cyr l'école
c'est une vraie opportunité pour la
ville de faire connaître ses bâtiments
historiques l'école militaire liée à thé
l'aérodrome
mais aussi de montrer à quel point cette
ville elle est agréable à vivre
deux boucles dans les yvelines et les
sols ou les spectateurs étaient au bord
des routes ou à leurs balcons des images
loin d'être inédite pour le département
j'ai dirigé dans plusieurs pays du monde
par plusieurs chaînes une découverte
extraordinaire des îles vide et c'est ça
qui justifie ce partenariat qui dure et
qui durera on est ravi de partir à
essence hier décoller à nouveau des
yvelines comme nous le faisons pour
paris nice depuis chaque année depuis
chaque année depuis 2010 et puis de se
projeter pour une semaine de course
magnifique avec un très beau plateau
après 166 km l'irlandais sam bennett
s'impose devant le champion de france
arnaud démare sur cette première étape
yvelinoise après saint cyr l'école c'est
au tour de watteville sur mansion
d'accueillir l'épreuve ce lundi 8 mars
cette petite commune du nord des mines
de 1100 habitants organisent pour la
première fois de son histoire le départ
de la course au soleil on a besoin
voilà d'être accueillis dans des villes
et elles le font très bien
yala gratin mondial qui hélas et c'est
le charme du vélo de pouvoir faire ça on
pourra pas emmener le psg joue sur mon
chien ni l'équipe de france de football
mais on peut emmener les meilleurs
accords signés du monde
alors on sait que vous êtes un passionné
de cyclisme ça vous fait quoi de voir
ses coureurs des paris-nice est
caen-lyon ici dans votre ville bah je
les avais une joie dans pas mal de
villes comme je suis pas mal le tour de
france mais les voir dans ma commune
c'est une carte personnelle certes et
collectifs pour notre commune pour la
mettre en valeur pour la valoriser mais
je regarderai un grand bon souvenir en
tant qu'élu c'est la fin de ce paris
nice dans les yvelines rendez vous
l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition le département à une convention
avec aso jusqu'en 2025